JACOB RICHMAN: So we're
talking about Dart JavaScript.
[APPLAUSE]
In the past, using JavaScript
Interop meant verbose syntax
and giving up all
the static type
checking you take
for granted in Dart--
so you'd miss your ID
autocompletions, everything
you love about Dart.
And worse, performance
was also a problem,
because we wrapped every
single object when it passed
between JavaScript and Dart.
The new type JavaScript
Interop facade
give you the same terse
syntax and static type
analysis you expect
for Dart, but for all
your JavaScript libraries.
And equally importantly,
we no longer
wrap any objects when we
pass them across the Interop
boundary-- so you don't have
to worry about wrapping causing
a lot of performance overhead.
Let's take a look at a simple
example using the chart JS
library to see how hard
Interop was for even
a really simple use case.
Well, first, look at
the JavaScript version
of this example, because
unfortunately, it's much easier
to read than the Dart version.
In this example,
all we're doing is
we are getting a canvas
rendering context 2D object.
We're creating a data set.
Configuring some
styles for the chart.
Defining the labels
for the chart.
Creating a data set
with three points.
And then, rendering the data.
To a chart object.
Passing in that canvas.
So pretty simple.
But here's what the Dart
version looked like.
Unfortunately, this code's
a lot harder to read,
because of the verbose syntax
for method calls, property
accesses, and
invoking constructors.
And the verbose calls to
jsify don't help either.
This code barely
fits on my side,
so let's zoom in a bit to
understand it in more detail.
So if you use Dart
HTML a lot, you'll
wonder why we're
having to call the
get context method with the
JS Interop call method syntax.
The reason is the
old Interop only
let you pass a small number
of types between Dart
and JavaScript-- and
CanvasRenderingContext2D
wasn't one of those types.
So we had to pass the
canvas object to JavaScript
and then, call the
JavaScript method on it
to make sure we're
playing nicely.
If we hadn't done
that, we would have
end up passing an
opaque dark candle
to the
CanvasRenderingContext2D object
and JavaScript would have had
no idea what to do with it.
And then, here are
the jsify calls again.
In addition to being verbose,
these were also really slow.
Because when you
make this call, you
have to recursively
copy every object
within the map and
any maps or lists
within the map to
convert them over
to the correct JavaScript types.
For a simple example,
this wouldn't
be a performance problem.
But imagine if you're trying
to plot 10,000 points,
now you're having
to worry about this.
And calling a
JavaScript constructor
was also not really
very obvious.
Looking at that line above,
it's not really clear
that I'm just creating
a new chart object
and passing in those parameters.
So why was Interop so hard?
Superficially,
Dart and JavaScript
have a lot of commonalities.
Both languages have first
class functions, properties,
and do not require
method overloading.
It seems really
reasonable that you
should be able to call
JavaScript methods from Dart
using that same Dart
syntax you're used to,
instead of all this
extra friction we
saw in the previous slide.
So one of the challenges
was supporting
Dartium with performance
suitable to deploy
a large application.
Dartium had two separate
VMs, one for JavaScript
and one for Dart.
Having separate VMs
meant high overhead
for every single call
between the two VMs.
Even with our best efforts,
you could really only expect
about 50,000 calls
between VMs per second--
that meant that if we encouraged
you to accidentally have
to go back and forth
between Dart and JavaScript
for every element in that
100,000 element array,
that's going take two seconds--
that's not really good.
So the new JavaScript
Interop has
to work correctly in Dartium,
but the performance only
needs to be good
enough for developing
your app-- it doesn't have to
be good enough for production,
so this gave us a
lot more flexibility.
We also get to ignore some
tricky garbage collection
issues that occur.
Because once again, it's
a development environment,
so if we leak a little bit of
memory, doesn't really matter.
So implementing really
good Interop in Dart2Js
was challenging, but for
really different reasons.
So Dart2Js depends on a
whole program analysis
to efficiently compile your
code to a small JavaScript
and with obeying all
the Dart semantics.
As Vijay was just discussing,
matching those Dart semantics
is really important and a
big reason why you use Dart.
This meant we couldn't just
choose some Interop scheme that
looked really nice, but
ended up breaking the Dart
semantics in really surprising
and unpredictable ways.
So if we use the Dart
no such method feature
to implement JavaScript Interop,
we actually get really close.
We achieve natural
looking JavaScript calls
to JavaScript methods, and
we get the right runtime
semantics.
Essentially, you have no such
method turn-around and call
JavaScript with exactly
the same method or property
name, and exactly the
same list of arguments.
Unfortunately, this
hurts Dart2Js performance
pretty badly.
I'll make Steven
Adams really sad
if I try to explain why, so
if you want to know more,
check out his really excellent
talk from the Dart summit
last year.
So we mitigated the flaws and
the no such method solution
with what I like to call
some such method-- what
this means is that the Dart2Js
compiler, instead of having
to assume that any possible
method could be coming
from JavaScript, it only has
to worry about method names
and numbers of arguments
that actually exist
and the type definitions
for the JavaScript libraries
you're using.
And in practice, this mitigates
most of the issue with the no
such method solution.
The Dartium solution actually
does just use no such method,
because no such method
isn't a problem in Dartium.
And so, when you're
using the new Interop,
remembering that it is
expressible in terms
of no such method
can really help
you understand what's
going to happen--
because our solution is
constrained by the semantics.
And it's going to make
it easier to understand
what will happen for some
of the tricky edge cases,
such as if you try to tear of a
function on a JavaScript class.
In this case, the
call to no such method
will just look like
a property access,
so you will access the property
on the JavaScript class--
which happens to be a function.
So because all we require
for JavaScript correctness is
the right member names and
numbers of allowed arguments,
the Dart facades for JavaScript
libraries can be approximate--
and this is really important,
because JavaScript types
are approximate.
Like VJ was talking
about, no one's
actually tacking the
types at runtime.
So if we really depended
tightly on the types,
you could end up broken in a
way that you couldn't get out
of-- because it really was
a cat instead of a dog,
but that was OK, because the
cat did have the bark method.
So often type definitions
from JavaScript libraries
were actually created
by a different author
than the original
library authors,
so that's another way you
get some small errors.
Fortunately, even these
approximate JavaScript type
definitions are really useful
for your editor experience.
You still get really
good code complete
and you still catch the
standard compile time errors.
So the new Interop solutions
user facing API is package:js.
So package:js has a
really small API surface,
it's really just these
two annotations--
@JS and @anonymous.
You just use @JS to indicate
whether libraries, classes,
and top-level members are
coming from JavaScript.
So here's some of the types
you can share between Dart
and JavaScript using package:js
without ever having to worry
about conversions or wrappings.
The only case we can't make
as seamless as we'd like
is passing a function
from Dart to JavaScript.
For this case, you
do have to call
allow Interop on a function.
After you do that, it
becomes a function that's
safe to use in both
Dart and JavaScript--
we had to do this for Dart2Js.
It's possible we can remove
this constraint in the future.
Thanks to strong
mode and some ES6
features, Dart Dev Compiler
doesn't have this constraint.
So just one warning.
Don't combine the old JS
Interop and package:js.
You'll get really
strange behavior,
because package:js is assuming
there is never any wrapping
and dart:js is
wrapping everything--
so you can really quickly end up
passing wrappers to JavaScript,
where it's not going
to be a good time.
So let's see how the package:js
library works for the chart.js
library we examined earlier.
So here is a snippet
from the Dart JavaScript
facade for the chart
library that we looked at.
Generally, this just looks
like a regular Dart class.
And even without knowing
anything about Interop,
it's pretty obvious
what is going on.
You can see this full
definition if you go to the web
address in the bottom.
So what's going on here?
This is the JS
annotation that indicates
that the library
used JS Interop-- you
have to include that.
In the future, expect
tight integration
with JS module loaders,
so you could specify
where to load the module as
part of this annotation--
so you can let Dart fully
control when the JavaScript
libraries are loaded in.
So a library with
this annotation
can still have some regular Dart
classes and top-level members.
So these annotations
indicated that the classes
are coming from JavaScript, they
are not regular Dart classes.
And because there are just
facades for JavaScript classes,
all members must be external
without actual Dart method
bodies.
Generally, we found this
restriction is actually
beneficial as it is far easier
to leverage existing JavaScript
examples for API if you
resist the temptation to make
the API more Dart-y.
And as I said, Dart
in JavaScript syntax
is generally compatible
enough that you don't really
need to make the API
more Darty-- it would
be more something
you do, because it
seemed tempting than
something you had to do.
You'll generally, have a better
time if you use the new JS
Interop for JavaScript libraries
created around the past five
years, because of more of a nice
object-oriented structure that
will make them convenient
to use from Dart.
So what's this
anonymous annotation?
That indicates that this
JavaScript class just
corresponds to a
JavaScript object literal,
not a class with
a real JavaScript
constructor-- it's
something people
love to do in JavaScript.
And using the
annotation is really
useful for giving structured
APIs that otherwise would just
be a big bag of properties.
If you had a typo and entered
the wrong property name,
now, you'll get an
obvious Dart static error
instead of just having
the program keep going
and probably never even throw
an exception in JavaScript--
because it's not
really a big deal
to have some additional
property on an object
that the library
wasn't expecting.
The other big reason for
this pattern is performance.
We can compile a
factory constructor
like this down to just the
raw JavaScript object literal.
While for the jsify case, we
had to recursively traverse
the contents of the object
and convert it to a JavaScript
literal at that point.
And so, notice that we're
able to describe this methods
arguments in terms of
the familiar Dart list
class instead of JavaScript
specific array class--
which could require some
expensive conversions
to create.
This makes a really big
performance difference
on Dart2Js.
Of course, this
design isn't efficient
for us to implement
in Dartium and it
took some crazy code to make
the regular Dart VM list object
mimic a JavaScript array
object well enough on Dartium
to fool almost all
JavaScript libraries.
One thing to watch
out for about arrays.
This only works for the
built-in Dart list class.
If you have some
custom list class,
make sure you call the
two list method on it
before passing it to JavaScript.
Unfortunately,
JavaScript doesn't
have the features to let you
create your own custom list
array like classes.
This is actually OK in
practice, because most
of the lists you
have in your program
are probably core
list types anyway.
And if they're not, you
probably did something wrong
and it's probably slowing
down your performance.
So as you can see, it's fine for
a Java [INAUDIBLE] facade class
to implement another class.
In this case, the linear chart
data implements the chart data
class-- and that
that's just fine,
it won't cause any issues.
And so, as we discussed
earlier-- previously,
you had to pass in
a JavaScript object
for the CanvasRenderingContext2D
rather than
just the regular
object in Dart HTML.
Now, you don't have to do it.
All the Dart HTML types are
fine to use with Interop.
So let's look back at that
old example from Dart:js.
Here's what it looks like now.
So in this version,
it's pretty easy
to read-- everything's
statically typed.
If you wanted to know what
other options the data set
object takes, just
right click in your IDE
and jump to the definition.
If you had a typo in
any of the API names,
you are now going to
get a static type error,
and you'll be able to catch
the error before you actually
run your application.
And so, that yeah we did.
I spelled colour with
the British spelling.
And so, in the
previous example that
wouldn't have broken
anything, we just
didn't have the right
background color.
Now, we do.
So let's fix that.
So what does our Dart:js compile
output for this example look
like?
It's great if the
code is easy to write,
but if the compile
output's not terse,
we haven't really achieved much.
So here's the output.
You can see all
those Dart classes
that were giving structure
to JavaScript a object
literal just compiled down
directly to the JavaScript
object literal.
So this is the actual code
from Dart2Js-- it just looks
like the idiomatic JavaScript.
There is one of the
object literals.
And you'll notice
setting the data property
on the data set looks
a little bit different,
but that's just
the Dart2Js syntax
to make sure that you handle
Dart semantics correctly.
So if you happen to have an
object where Dart2Js couldn't
figure out whether it
was a JavaScript data
set or some Dart class that
had the same interface,
everything would still
work in this case.
So now, it's time
for some fun demos.
The good news is that
type JavaScript facade
we looked out for
chart.js wasn't something
that I generated
myself, it's something
we generated automatically based
on existing TypeScript library
definition.
So let's try out that tool.
So here we go.
This is the code lab application
from the dev compilers work
flow yesterday.
So I'm just going to
call the Dart JS facade
gen on the TypeScript definition
for the chart library.
When I do that-- OK.
Here's the definition.
You can see here are
all the types from Dart
HTML that the library's using.
We're able to get the canvas
gradient, canvas pattern,
and a bunch of other
Dart HTML types.
And then, keep
going here, we can
see all the different classes
I was able to extract out.
So clearly, this
is more code than I
would have wanted to write by
hand if I was using a library--
but someone else already
wrote this, so I'm done.
Now, in that example VJ
showed in that last talk,
we used the Quill library.
Let's try generating the
facade for that instead.
OK.
Looks pretty good.
Let's copy it over the code app.
After I run the
tool, you'll notice
that dev compiler's
running in the lower tab,
and it saw the change and
recompiled everything.
So I'm ready to actually
try out the application.
And I have really
blown up my font,
so you can't see
the application,
but you see the
dev tools for it--
because I love the
dev tools, so we're
going to actually focus on that.
Now, the feature that I'm
really excited to demonstrate
that we have working
in just regular Chrome
is a Dart specific
console, where
you can issue arbitrary
Dart statements,
compile them, and run them
as part of your already
running applications.
This all works, because the Dev
Compiler works incrementally.
So let's see if this is
really running Dart here.
So in my JavaScript
console down here,
I could see whether a 1
is not equal the string 1.
Oh yeah, that makes
sense-- it's JavaScript.
If I go over to my Dart
consol-- so there we go.
Clearly, we're
actually running Dart.
[APPLAUSE]
But it gets a lot
more fun than that.
This can also be a nice way to
play around with what the dev
compiler output looks like.
For example, I could define
a function in the console.
Here, I've defined a function
that takes two integers
and adds them together.
And it happens the
console is calling
to string on the object.
So here, I can see the
actual source code.
So this function is checking
whether the two arguments
are not null.
And if they're not null, it's
just adding them together.
Back
In the regular
JavaScript console,
you can see that this
function actually
has a type int comma int to
dynamic, which makes sense.
If on the other hand, I had
omitted the types for the two
arguments, now you can
see Dev Compiler realizes
this is a dynamic call-- so it
calls the dynamic call helper,
descend, to invoke the call.
So you can get a feel for how
adding types helps things.
And of course, a wrapper
wouldn't be really useful
if you couldn't use it on
your running application.
Over here, here is a
captain log, .DartFiles,
part of the application.
I can right click on it.
And say, open using the
Dev Compiler debugger.
And now, it set the context
of this Dart console
to that library.
So I can access any top
level member from that class.
So log element.
OK.
There it is.
It's an HTML element.
We've got the map
of log entries.
Makes sense it's a Dart
hash map with those keys.
This will work even if these are
private members in your class.
And one fun feature, guys.
You can even access private
members in other classes.
Because we know when
you're compiling code just
for the dev tools, you
want to access privates
from other libraries.
You don't need the
sort of normal safe
you'd have in
[INAUDIBLE], you really
want to be able to
access the privates.
Let's see, what
else can we do here?
We could access a
particular log entry,
so we can get the
last entry in the log.
yes.
So, OK.
So last entry is
the development.
What if I wanted
to see the text?
OK.
You can see I call
the Dart HTML text
property, instead of having to
worry about what the JavaScript
name was.
And down here, you see what
the last entry was in the log.
And of course, I've kept
these expressions small just
to avoid too many typos.
But you can also write
a full Dart expression.
So here, I've got a
Dart [INAUDIBLE] loop,
where I printed all the elements
in the log to the console.
And it all just worked.
So that's pretty fun.
We're pretty excited about this.
So it'll let you get the
same sort of experience
you had in Dartium,
but in Dev Compiler.
So I'll get back to
the rest of the slides
and then it will be time
for some lunch, which
seems pretty exciting too.
So the JS facade generator even
works when some of the types
aren't expressable in
Dart-- in those cases,
the facade generator will
simplify the type to something
expressible in Dart and leave
a Dart version of the raw type
in a [INAUDIBLE].
So this is really
nice, because you
don't have to go back to the
original library definition
to figure out what
you're trying to say.
For example, they might have
been using union types or pair
types-- some feature that
doesn't exist in Dart,
but does in TypeScript.
And there's also
an escape hatch.
Sometimes you really want
to do something dynamic
with JavaScript and the
JS facades won't really
let you do that, because
they're focused on letting
you use a specific static API.
There is JS utile library,
part of packet JS,
that gives you the escape
hatch you need for that case.
And generally speaking,
these methods look a lot like
the methods you're
used to for JS object,
except these are static methods,
and they're really fast,
and they work well with
the type JS Interop-- well,
dart:js will blow it up.
So if you find
out you're wanting
to use these methods a
lot, please let me know.
I really want to know cases
where our existing Interop
isn't meeting your needs.
That probably indicates
there's some feature
we should be adding.
So we make consuming JavaScript
libraries from Dart easy,
but we don't really enable
cases like extending
JavaScript classes from
Dart or vice versa.
If you're interested in those
cases, the best place to look
is Dart Dev compiler, where
it is so tightly integrated
with JavaScript class syntax
and calling conventions
that those sorts of cases
are feasible in a kind
of efficient way.
The other thing we want to
do a little bit nearer term
is make future and promise
integrate well together, just
like list an array
integrate together.
And this will matter more and
more as new JavaScript APIs
take advantage of promises to
handle pass asynchronous calls.
[APPLAUSE]
So let us know how JS
Interop is working for you
and what features you need.
Thank you.
And let's enjoy lunch.
[APPLAUSE]